[Music]
so big boy
you yo have been very open and vocal
about your past
which is that you have spent time in
prison a little tiny
small amount of time yeah went on
vacation a little bit i call it vacay
or college i call it college when they
asked me i said go to college what state
penn state yeah oh yeah penn state i i
know colby
oh that's cool that's cool you know i
play it off like that the actual pen
state the
ivy league yeah yeah why didn't he name
him that then
i know i'm like oh what a big boy yeah
um but yeah so the reason why i bring
that up is because the story here that i
have
is they're talking about how prisoners
are going viral on tick tock and it's
just really shining a light on
life behind like so they have the phone
in there and they have a tick tock yeah
there's a lot of prisoners going viral
on tick tock right now but it's actually
it's it's um it's a good thing and
because it's humanizing a lot of
prisoners i followed a chef in prison
well he's not like a real chef
but this fool has like him and his
homies like they're all like bringing
out like random things and he goes
oh i melt the cheese like next to the
window or i do all these and he makes
like little culinary like
like lasagna with rocks that's just a
trick how they they're putting
themselves on
front street yeah yeah how are they not
getting busted i don't know
well there are some people that are they
talk about how like in a six-year span
or something like that they got caught
with two phones
and every time they both smell like
dookie though they end up getting like
solitary
that's a prison phone no they say that
they're actually saying that the
majority of the cell phones
because that cell phones in prison are
contraband that they're coming
you guys are wait wait let me say this
though if prison is looking for a guy to
check for prison phones bar it's going
to sign up for the job right
you got that good nose right hey and
bart bartlett smuggle your hot sauce in
too
yeah okay that might be easier that's
his pocket they call that the pocket
is it put in your pocket yup wow he
wants to be a mule what do they call
pockets
huh they call those are your [ __ ]
[Laughter]
vice versa
oh really i thought the whole inside out
thingy with the pockets and the thing
you hold somebody's pocket near their
[ __ ] you have to walk
they you have to put your hands in your
pants you walk there under the waistband
uh-huh yeah
yeah interesting uh but yeah so they
were saying that the majority of these
cell phones that are getting smuggled
into prisons they're
they're coming through the staff like i
heard of that
staff are the ones but there are other
methods like they'll
they'll open a football and like throw
it over the fence
like they'll stuff cell phones inside of
a football and like throughout the
counselors or like they'll drop it
through a drone
or like they'll do other stuff a drone
yeah that's high
tech that's some great damn
i thought they just paid a guard well
it's mostly that oh okay mostly
through this but some guards don't
listen to you go over with the drone
damn that's smart how do you know which
guards are for sale
gotta have that mouthpiece what's that
she's gotta have good vocals yeah
oh i see good at manipulating people so
my um
my buddy he um he was working at the
courts
he's a uh and he was telling me that the
way that they did it
was one of the daughters of this
high-profile
gangster she was basically coming in
and then she'll see who the most
friendliest cop is
and then she'll always offer them food
and all this stuff
he was having trials so she would come
to visit and she would always look sexy
and all this stuff
and then whoever bites the bait she'll
start
giving him food or all these other
things wow and then
they might hook up or i don't know she's
a honeypot basically
wow and then well that's just one of the
ways right and then he was saying like
um
then they found out that the food that
she was giving
one of the officers was actually uh
ended up being drugs in the food
and then he would give it to her dad as
a
she's like can you give this to my dad
and all this stuff and then later
he he was a part of the take and then he
he couldn't stop doing it
wow and so there's a lot of instances
where things like this
go down so there's i don't know people
find their way it's
did anyone escape while you were in
escape no [ __ ]
he was like come on come on that's movie
[ __ ] yeah it happens though
i've heard like in the oc jail a couple
dudes escaped oh [ __ ] oh yeah after that
that was like a couple years ago right
crazy but no no one no no all right so i
have a video to show you guys
and it's just like a short i want to see
two yeah so it's like a short video
and this is a cali jail no like all
around the country
all around the country prisoners are
going viral on tick tock
yeah cali jelly ain't active like the
cali jail huh
okay we got the most prisons in all the
united states oh yeah
yeah you know that got to be proud of
that
such a wonderful state you know okay
here we go
yeah this is definitely not cali boy
come to prison to talk
what yeah i ain't associated with this
right here i ain't associated with this
morning for our coffee people became so
hyped i think the stuff you see right
see what it's like behind
the wall there's better camera angles
that was a good trade that i posted
there's trays that are in there that are
so gross like
it'll run away from you before you eat
it i mean that's literally how we had to
make our water because they don't have
hot water spigots or anything
everything on canteen that they do sell
requires to be cooked so
the only way to cook it is to macgyver
or something what
that's pretty cool like behind the wall
and there's not all bad people in there
the virality of tick tock
helps us actually see the thing that's
so
that's a nice jail to hide from us i
told you
saint cali boy
[Laughter]
one thing i knew that it was a bunch of
kids on there so i kind of wanted to
post it as like a reality of what would
happen if you go to prison
and it's not any place that you want to
end up a lot of people my age right now
it looks like a pretty fun place there i
know it's like i kind of want to go to
jail
and people's posting pictures like i
follow guys like that
this desperation is a desperation of
connection
to other humans to communities to
support systems to
life to the rest of the world and
and a reminder that you exist we will be
like
oh my gosh you're dating someone in
prison why would you stop your life like
that
and i'm like oh where i hadn't seen any
prison
prison videos on tick tock at that time
so then i started coming up with all the
hashtags
so it's it's pretty much like showcasing
how tick-tock has allowed
people behind prison walls to connect
with
society and also but obviously
lawmakers they don't like that because
then it's highlighting how inhumane
these prison conditions really are and
that's causing people to really be like
the [ __ ] like this is how people are
living in prisons like how how do they
not have hot water
with forty dollar uh forty thousand
dollars a year per inmate
that's the the what they're spend like
that makes no sense i'm sure it goes to
the inmate it's
uh it's wonderful i mean we have a big
[ __ ] penal colony that's our country
but
so like the way the prison private
prison system works is
for each inmate it's roughly about forty
thousand dollars that the private prison
gets to take care of them
that goes to the cost of you know admin
and whatever
but they're probably spending very very
little
on taking care of that inmate and then
that money is just going into their
pockets like all the money that's
supposed to go to the kids in schools
yeah that's true or all the money is
supposed to go on fixing our roads
or the where's that money what's going
into the into all the cones they buy
that costs like a thousand dollars they
put all these cones and then nobody's
working at all
i love it that's [ __ ] crazy what are
your thoughts on this
on that um on like tick-tock
highlighting life is this a back in my
day speech you're about to give i can
see it
the way that you took a deep breath
that's some new age [ __ ] for sure
well from like the new age was it when
you when you were
um 06 to 10 yeah
so that's already over 10 years yeah did
they get soft since you left come on you
want to say it
i wouldn't imagine like dudes in jail
doing tick tocks well this is like i
said this isn't cali
so like i can't you know you can't
compare
if you got cali prison and you got
everybody else's
and uh i mean there's so many i don't
even want to talk too much but
there's so much politics in california
state prisons that like
a lot of things aren't okay unless we're
talking about like a pcr
s and y yard like where you got the
snitches and the rapists and things like
that
that's a free-for-all that's you know
that's i don't know what they do over
there but that's a free-for-all when you
say politics you're talking general
population
politics your behavior is controlled by
the gangs too
or the leaders that's the only thing
it's controlled by right so that's what
you mean by like
other ceos say yeah it's not with the
ceos it's what our people say
but then these guys they're we don't run
the ceos program ever
and these guys can do tick tocks because
maybe from the prisons that they're in
they don't have those no politics yeah
uh-huh
what would be some of the politics that
you have to like oh
you don't even want to speak on those
things bart other secrets you got to be
behind the walls to know those
things you know i see saving it for your
book right
saving it for your book oh yeah my
tell-all book no that ain't happening
for me he told us off-camera he's
written a tell-all book about all this
very exciting to read it why are you
trying to get them in trouble
i heard that the rules are different per
race too politics
yeah all politics yeah every every they
have to follow different rules that we
do
every race every gang every whatever has
their own politics
you know so your people my people will
all have our own things that we got to
do
you know what would your tech talk have
looked like my tick-tock
thinking um
i'm trying to think because i think at
that time i think at that time
i think my space was around okay my
space
oh and i want to say some people maybe
had a myspace i can't remember
like i said like in there it was like
flip phones and but from your routine
small bowls like what you were doing
constantly what would it be
man i don't even know my mindset back
then wasn't
even thinking about that so making
content yeah
i didn't even know what it was until i
really
started making content um when i got
into making content i had maybe had an
instagram for
two or three weeks and that dude rich
piana hit me up so i had
no clue what it was and someone just
immediately hit me up and put me up on
game
but before that i had no clue what
really youtube
or anything was well it's not a very
good answer yeah
so probably i just probably wouldn't
have had it okay because i didn't know
that
this was even a thing you know i got you
what was that push-up program you told
me about there's this program like
a certain way that you do it it's easier
to count numbers so you could do work up
with it to a thousand
oh like i would do 1250 push-ups a day
every morning in one second child no no
just in
20 sets oh so i'll do like on 1
5 10 15 and 20 i would do 100 reps and
all the numbers in between i do 50
and it'd be like 1250. looking at a
clock or what no no that would just be
me
like like in the cell before i go to
chow in the morning so set one you do a
hundred yeah you get up like at four
whatever 4 30
bang these out get ready go to chow you
know
go grub how long do you wait before the
next 100
i would just when i feel good just go
nice yeah
seems like that's easy i finished that
before before i even go to sleep
i can't believe you only did 1200. and
you did 1200 um
every day every single day yeah
i just said something stupid in my head
what'd you say you were like
uh i finished that before going to sleep
and in my head i was like yeah he's like
oh i finished that while i'm taking the
[ __ ]
like that makes no sense you could take
it you could do push-ups on the [ __ ]
so dumb yeah it's okay we're done
[Music]
[Music]
you